hey 42 here as another steamy dawn broke
over a gorge in London in 1790 and
unassuming but marvelous inventor
proudly placed a new feature in his shop
front in one to four Piccadilly it was a
black wooden plaque inscribed with
beautiful golden hand lettering that
read the artist who can make an
instrument that will pick or open this
lock shall receive 200 guineas the
moment it is produced at the top of the
board was mounted a circular iron
padlock and the item with which security
lived and died this was a challenge to
all passers-by whoever could
successfully pick this lock would be
awarded 200 guineas worth over twenty
thousand pounds today its creator was so
confident that he had produced the
world's first totally unpickable lock
Joseph Bramah was born on a farm in
Barnsley Yorkshire but his fascination
for invention and the newly born field
of mechanical engineering brought him to
London he started out his career making
cabinets and an improved water closet
which overcame a perennial issue that
many wealthy Lu owners in London were
having the water in the toilet froze in
the colder months which led to some
unfortunate side effects Brahmas new
water closet design which he created
with his boss mr. Allen was so
successful that it was produced for over
100 years until more modern designs
arrived in the late 19th century when a
certain mr. crapper came along Brahmas
water closet was even supplied to Queen
Victoria and a working model can still
be found in her most favorite residence
Osborne house on the Isle of Wight
Brahma also invented the hydraulic press
so you can thank him for the countless
hours you've spent watching various
household objects being obliterated on
YouTube he also drew up plans for an
early fountain pen invented the beer
engine which allowed beer to be pumped
up to the taps in the bar unless the
kegs could be kept in the cool cellar
below and he invented the first machine
that allowed banknotes to have a unique
sequential number printed on each
one quite the incredible inventor he was
but it was a foray in the 1780s with
which Brammer left his most famous
legacy he attended a series of lectures
on locks and became obsessed with them
in 1784 he started the brahmalok company
at 124 Piccadilly where he would design
manufacture and sell his own proprietary
locks locks up to this point were
absolute shite amazingly the first pin
and tumbler lock where the key must
raise bolts to a very specific height
freeing the barrel so that it can freely
rotate and lock the basis of the same
design we use today were first created
6,000 years ago in ancient Egypt they
were constructed from wood and as
remarkable as this was for the time they
were predictably on secure the Greeks
and Romans built on this technology very
slightly but since the first century
until the 18th century absolutely no
progress was made at all unlock design
for thousands of years locks were
painfully simple to pick they could
indeed be picked with a single wooden
stick
they were so easy in fact that during
the Middle Ages security consisted of
creating a series of fake keyholes on
doors with the hope that there would be
lock breaker would try the wrong keyhole
first then just give up and go home
seriously Joseph Bramah set out to
create the world's first unpickable lock
but there was good reason why no such
luck yet existed engineering up to this
point was incredibly imprecise all pots
were hammered out by hands then filed
down to the appropriate size and shape
this meant that if a factory produced a
hundred iron door handles per day then
each one would be of greatly different
dimensions and each would have their own
unique imperfections this imprecision
impeded the improvement of very small
mechanisms such as locks actually it is
a testament to the great imprecision of
engineering in the mid 18th century that
the word mechanism was only now coming
into existence luckily for Brahma he
employed an 18-year old assistant in his
workshop who would soon go on to change
the world
Henry Maudsley Maudsley was a bright and
highly inquisitive young man who working
with Brahma invented the world's first
machine tools that is a machine that can
create very precise parts for other
machines by cutting boring grinding or
shearing metals one of the most
influential and useful of Maude's lee's
machine tools was the metal lathe which
enabled the production of standardised
screw sizes and interchangeable parts
without mod sleaze innovations mass
production and the Industrial Revolution
would not have been possible almost
every single item in your house and on
your driveway today would not exist but
that's a story for another time this
video is about Brahma Brahma used the
new machine tools he and Moseley had
created to design and mass-produce a new
series of Brahma lakhs to sell in his
shop for discerning London as a need of
better security the locks all had
interchangeable parts and was so
precisely machines that apart from the
lock combination no two were different
which although very normal today at the
time was groundbreaking Brahmas lakhs
employed a patented design with a
cylindrical barrel and a number of
wafers tiny slices of spring-loaded
metal that would push themselves into
the center of the barrel only when the
correct tubular key was inserted pushing
the wafers outside of the barrel could
the lock rotate and thus open Brahma
took his lock design and created one
particular lock with 18 wafers meaning
that there were 470 million possible
permutations for the wafers and only one
of those could
open the lock this would be his
challenge lock that he placed proudly in
his shop window so secure he thought
that no man alive or two could pick it
open and he was so confident that he was
willing to put 200 guineas on it many
tried many expert locksmiths from the
world over and laymen alike took up the
challenge but it's extremely numerous 18
wafers and it's tricky
she Buehler design fooled even the very
best it quickly grew in Fame and the
world's media reported on the world's
first unpickable lock it would appear
that the idea of perfect security a
security system that cannot be breached
had been achieved in fact by the time
Joseph Bramah died aged 66 the lock
still remained as stoically unpacked at
which point his children took over his
business it would be almost seventy
years since its carnation that the
brahma challenged lock would meet its
match the British government
particularly its various security
divisions and its prison service were
intensely interested in Brahmas lock but
they had an added requirement for an
impeccable lock they wanted a lock that
could alert the owner if a peeking
attempt had been made so any attempted
break-ins at various government
institutions could be detected the
British government was so eager to
acquire such technology especially after
a portsmouth dockyard was burgled in
1817 that they held a nationwide
competition offering a one hundred pound
reward eight thousand pounds today for
anyone who could invent such a lock a
year later a man named Jeremiah Chubb
stepped forward to claim the reward he
had invented what he named the Chubb
detector lock it was reportedly both
unpickable and would also alert the
owner to an attempted break-in by
jamming itself during a pickin attempt
and after it had been jammed it could
then only be unlocked even by the owner
by first resetting the detector
mechanism with a special regular
Tukey the British government were
impressed but they wanted to test its
real-life effectiveness before and
playing the Chubb detector lock across
the country so they came up with a
rather unconventional test the gays a
lock to a prisoner in Portsmouth who is
considered a leading expert in lock
picking he was a locksmith by trade and
had been able to pick every single lock
he had ever come across if he could
successfully pick the lock the
government were prepared to release him
from prison and give him 100 pound the
man's freedom was quite literally at
stake he tried tirelessly for free mumps
in his cell but could not pick the
detector lock and he threw in the towel
so impressed with the British government
that the chip detector lock became the
de facto industry standard lock for
Britain and was used in prisons post
offices government buildings and by
hundreds of private corporations with
the chip detector lock and Brahmas
challenge lock it seemed the world had
to own pickable locks that was until the
great slot controversy of 1851 the Great
Exhibition the world's first
international show of technology
organized by Queen Victoria's husband
Albert was held after the specially
built Crystal Palace in Hyde Park in
October of 1851 new technologies from
every corner of the earth were on
display amongst all the spectacles on
exhibit were Brahmas challenge lock
which by this point had gone on picked
for 67 years and the Chubb detector lock
a pioneering American locksmith and lock
salesman Alfred C Hopps made a special
trip on a steamship from Washington to
sell his own products at the London
exhibition but secretly he had another
more alluring motive he had come to be
the first map to pick the unpickable
locks upon arriving at the Great
Exhibition Hobbs remarkably managed to
pick the Chubb detector
he did this by repeatedly tripping the
detector mechanism and then picked it
again to reset the mechanism each time
he did this he learned more and more
about how the device worked until he was
eventually able to open the lock itself
using basic lock-picking tools hops then
picked it again in front of a fascinated
crowd in only seven minutes and with
this the belief in the impenetrable
security of the nation had evaporated
but for Hobbes this was only a warm-up
act the true prize was the 67 year old
unbreakable challenge the Brahma so
important to the government
Joseph Brahmas children's business and
the idea of true security to the entire
world was the imperviousness of the
Brahma challenge lock that a committee
was set up to determine rules for Hobbes
attempt the rules were as follows Hobbes
had 30 days to attempt the challenge the
lock was affixed to a wall to limit
access to only the keyhole and the hasp
the key was to be locked away during the
attempt whenever the lock was left
unattended the keyhole was to be covered
by an item buttoned if Hobbes was
successful he had to prove that the key
could once again lock and open the
padlock to prove that he hadn't opened
it through damage Hobbes would have to
carry out the attempt in a room above
Brahmas shop and a moderator would
periodically check in on him this was
obviously a serious affair and much more
than 200 guineas were at stake and
Hobbes was taking it seriously he had
brought with him specially made tiny
mirrors so small they could fit inside
the keyhole to lock and diamond tools
over the next 16 days and the total of
51 hours Hobbes slaved away to pick the
unpickable and on the 23rd of August
1851 the short age of perfect security
ended Hobbes had picked open Brahmas
lock without any damage
the event has gained the name the great
Locke controversy of 1851 because the
committee's initial forms were that
Hobbes had completed this challenge in
such a controlled environment it was
such a prolonged period that it was
entirely or representative of a
real-life burglary they were not pleased
yet the two hundred guineas were but
grudgingly handed over but with it
they also handed over the end of a time
when a man could put a lock on his front
door and feel safe in the knowledge that
nobody could get in at least not without
brute force there has never again been a
lot that has remained unpicked for so
long even the most cutting edge locks
today are unlikely to last a fraction of
the time as Brahmas I've recently
launched my first book which I'm
crowdfunding stick a flag in it a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond the crowdfunding
campaign has reached a hundred percent
so it's definitely going to be published
thanks to everyone who has pledged but
there are still stretch goals to reach
so if you want a first edition signed
copy then head on over to UM bounds the
links in the description watch the
launch video if you haven't already and
pledge today thank you